I find crypto fun and really interesting
and I've always been into Tech I like
futuristic things so that's why I have a
genuine interest in crypto but with
Bitcoin I think it will be Mass adopted
out of desperation so you will wake up
when you're desperate for a solution
Canada the truckers were protesting the
rights to their own body how did the
government try and shut down this
protest by freezing their bank accounts
your bank account's Frozen how you going
to feed yourself yeah I get that so when
you come for someone's money you're
coming for their livelihood you're
coming for their ability to live but my
portfolio is 90% Bitcoin probably like
5% ethereum and then the rest like
lines